يعود الى السلطه بعد تزحمه المعارضه لاشهر
عده ليقود ما يصفه محللون بالحكومه الاكثر
يمينيه في تاريخ اسرائيل
وهو بعد ان فاز في انتخابات الاول من
تشرين الثاني نوفمبر والتي كانت الخامسه
خلال اربع سنوات شرعا في مفاوضات مع
الاحزاب الدينيه المتشدده واليمنيه
المتطرفه من بينها حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
بزعامه اثمار
الداخلي مع توسيع سلطته من قبل البرلمان
لتشمل جهاز الشرطه ايضا خطاب هذا المحامي
يمكن تلخيصه في تفضيل القوه على
الدبلوماسيه يريد مثلا التحكم في قواعد
اطلاق النار حتى تتمكن قوه الامن يطلق
النار على اي شخص يلوح بالحجاره او
القنابل الحارقه
زعيم الصهيونيه الدينيه
يتسلم شؤون الاداره المدنيه سيقود ملف
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه المحتله حيث
يعيش ما يقرب من ثلاثه ملايين فلسطيني
طالته اخطر موجه عنف منذ الانتفاضه
الثانيه مع عزيمه على مواصله التوسع
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه التي يوجد بها
نحو
400,075 مستوطن يهودي في مستوطنات تعتبر
غير قانونيه بموجب القانون الدولي وزير
الدفاع المنتهي ولايته اعرب عن خوفه من
التوجه المتطرف للحكومه الجديده توجههم
راى انه يضر بامن اسرائيل